President Trump who signed an executive
order late Tuesday ordering meat
processing plans to stay open the plants
had been hard hit by this pandemic 22
have been closed so far due to
infections or fear of infections Dean
Reynolds reports from Chicago now on how
unions say the cost in workers lives is
not worth forcing the plants to stay
open this is about people that work Gary
Harris is a 20-year employee of the now
shuttered Tyson meat plant in Logansport
Indiana he's worried his health and that
of his coworkers are being unnecessarily
endangered before the talk about
reopening they should make sure safety
is first the United Food and Commercial
Workers Union or UFCW says 20 workers
have already died of the virus but with
meatpacking plants around the country
facing slowdowns and closures those
working there are now considered to be
essential employees here's why there
needed to move livestock now piling up
at farms because plants have shut down
leading to a reduction in beef and pork
processing livestock analyst Dennis
Smith these changes in production are so
severe that it's very likely to create a
shortage now the White House is trying
to mitigate the risk of that happening
with this latest executive order not
every job can be socially distanced in
that point a plan mark Lauritsen
represents meat processing plant workers
for the UFCW
he says Washington has a responsibility
to protect the workers as well as the
companies they took a step that said
we're gonna have these plants open and
operating at running they got to take
the next step to making sure enforceable
OSHA standards enforceable standards
from the CDC now groceries like this one
behind me are waiting to see the impact
of the president's executive order which
asks food processors to follow federal
safety and health guidelines and in a
statement to CBS News Tyson Foods for
example said the safety of its team
members remains a top fryer
Tyson adds that it's already
implementing social distancing cleaning
out its facilities and regularly taking
the temperature of its workers Gail all
right Dean thank you very much